Zombies they just keep on coming don't
they
especially in dying light the following
expansion yet this time around there's a
new way to deal with these dumb
butt-head pedestrians and it's with your
amazing yet ever so delicate huggy
so before you rev up that rod what do
you say we fuel up on some hot test
before we start this party let's get
through to basic tips when in doubt
firecracker those idiots starting the
engine and fueling up may take longer
than you think
and there's no telling when I heard a
viral just might ruin your getaway
unlock that nitro boost upgrade more on
that later
keep to the roads and the railroads
consider resisting the urge to hit those
ever so fresh off-road slopes not just
because an unfortunate landing might
force you to respawn your buggy well
whenever you hit a jump run through
obstacles splatter a zombie you're
taking damage and boy it can add up real
quick so check that map and plan ahead
hey but I'm not saying don't have fun
just be cautious how you handle each
type of zombie and her on actually
transitions quite nicely to the buggy
life flying through biters no prob big
goons are essentially roadblocks take
the beat or virals can catch up real
quick if you're not at top speed and
when they hitchhike hit that nice Rose
to shake them floaters this time around
are probably your worst enemies because
the faster you fly down that road the
harder it is to see he's walking
landmines coming and they do major
damage to not only you but your whip
avoid them at all costs or toads and
their stupid loogies base your attacks
off proximity meaning if they're roughly
in your path hit them to prevent them
from cheap shotting you as you zip by
and then of course full tiles on earth
if driving at night is your thing then
go for it
they're pretty much easy to lose once
you got nitro level 2 but if you really
want to be covered
I recommend the landmines upgrade but at
the end of the day you're gonna your
buggy up which means in order to keep
your hot rod in shape she's gonna need
fuel and screws lots of screws in fact
screwing around has never been this
productive the best way to find screws
and fuel is by searching vehicles
searching for utility bans and military
vehicles heighten your odds for some of
the more rare vehicle crafting materials
and if you're parched for gas you can
double down on a big rig trucks to gas
tanks but all-in-all the best thing for
you to do is go on periodic scavenging
sprees your best bet is making a trek to
the main highway here and just go to
town baby because you're looking not
only to repair your Hot Rod you're
looking to upgrade it and that's where
challenge posters come in my friends win
a challenge
get a buggy part blueprint the harder
the challenge the higher level blueprint
as a word of advice start off on some
easy medium challenges first off the bat
your car's got and some of these
challenges are practically impossible
without a higher driver skill level as
well as higher level buggy parts your
vehicle part blueprints are no different
than weapon blueprints
once their repairs are used up sign are
they're gone because of their lifespan
it's best to express conservation
consider this you just scored on a level
5 turbo part instinct is to strap that
puppy on hell yeah but right before you
hit the Outback on an aimless road trip
while I put it to waste squirrel it away
in your backpack only gnawing at it for
tough racing challenges draw your own
line on which blueprints are burners and
which ones aren't
last up your driver upgrades personally
this is as far as I've gone in the tree
it's in your best interest to max out
that nitro ASAP for races but hey
stylize your buggy to fit you if you got
any tips of your own do put them in the
comments below thanks for watching
you